going to Waffle House
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hello
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
thank you
it's the second chance
out of my car
really
that's our car
you need another cup of water
I don't need a top or anything else
[Applause]
thank you
Phoenix
championship
[Applause]
oh yeah he twice he tried to ram in here
and then
if I
Drive man
you're like a damn joke
he's gonna be the uh one of the tracker
and
um
thank you
[Music]
good job these guys will get out of work
last night
thank you
I don't know
yes sir are you sir
it's for you man
you hit any dogs
I didn't get any human being
all right
oh
yeah
I don't know
oh God
amazing things
about being sprayed again here we go
don't whine about being sprayed here we
stop doing anything when I got sprayed
crazy I didn't leave the scene to tell
you that that I need to quit
I didn't leave
until after our team
where is your Spring by the way believe
me
we leave five north he looked me dead in
my face started smiling maybe you turn
coming up the upper end came right here
made it right
I said I said notified
weapons
started in this point ended in this
point
but there's no East Point here
[Applause]
all that that Waffle House felt in our
jurisdiction
huh
yeah
oh no man's land up here
I know
don't say that I just picked it up
I was in the middle of picking it up
when this came out I don't even have my
equipment
yeah
I mean I was literally picking it up
from the shop when it came out
bleeding buddy yeah the window fell
I thought he kissed it
all right
now
right all these points
and solution and maybe just rub them
down with some dogs but other than that
there's
going to be a purpose
you know what's up
the owners in here
no they're not even bleeding they're
just just right now
he wasn't in it when it got hit
oh yeah he's going on
oh my God
okay okay
thank you thank you
everybody
yeah
sounds good thank you everybody
wow
have you ever seen this before the whole
time
everybody
um
at least seven
yeah
the guy that's in the yellow
let me go get some stuff
God
so none of us
don't leave the states
but it's like this is something more New
Year yeah
Chicago
watch anything
that's all that y'all get our call
earlier this morning on the interstate
they were telling us a truck and a
trailer well it was this guy which I
seen I said you sure it's not a tractor
after we don't pass him she said oh yeah
there's a tractor well he parked from
here he got on it again
down the road
I was about to pull you out of your car
and take your Crown Vic from you and I
was gonna that's what I was worried
about it
yeah
I wasn't expecting it but I know why
me too I mean everybody wants to get
there but sometimes
I'm just gonna do it right here and just
let it run down
foreign
[Laughter]
Walsh
um
Sergeant Watkins
[Music]
the east
so I could get out of there before that
OC really got me good and someone's like
taser and I was like oh my goodness and
I felt the tasing them I was like you
got to be kidding me what do you think
Barry because I was about to get him
again and I said no no no because I was
thinking one of us might not have that
uh non-flamable OC mine still might be
foreign
we're like all right let's go get it
we're like wait a minute reason I asked
me because I saw blue lights up here
I was like somebody chasing them and
then nobody was chasing him when I got
up here when he got to me I guess they
turned around and left
okay
I mean well I probably should have with
my car
could have definitely shot them damn
tires out right here though I don't
think it would have stopped it though no
it would have it would impacted it would
have just slowed it down a little bit
but man those things are pretty cool
somebody said something about Stop
Sticks like that shit
let's just be flopping around here
you'll see me you're right around the
fucking tire
next time Walsh jump on my hood and I'll
just get you right there and jump in on
yeah I bet you those tires got water in
them
oh yeah
foreign
I think me and you both had the slack
pulled out
we were ready I told you I said we're
about to take him because if he kept
going towards melting my heroes yeah
that's all she wrote I was trying to he
was no he was no shit a half a second
away oh yeah that was I was dead on him
I didn't want to kill him me and fucking
married right there with a slack out I
said very important I said we're gonna
take him there we got to take him
you were here and I was here
I had a real good shot from where I was
at positions
other car
I got something old
I'm gonna come sit in my passenger seat
right there
I don't know I didn't even know I was
wearing it
okay
there's some kind of pills in the top of
that there that I could see in there
when I was opening but they're in a
ballistics
awesome
one of y'all for a cup of ice water
[Music]
so did you guys ask him what his plan
was
they've been chasing them all morning
he came up 85.
he got on Camp Creek somewhere oh my God
and they mowing for the state right now